The
Hello and welcome, everyone.
This is active live guest stream
number 22.1.
I'm here with Dr.
Anna Lembke
and we are here to discuss
"dopamine and beyond" and
really looking forward
to this conversation.
And appreciate the time.
So to you for any introductory context
and then really looking forward
to this discussion.
Yeah.
Well,
thank you so much for having me, Daniel.
You know, I've
been, you know,
interested in you
and your work for many years now.
And so I'm really excited
to have an excuse to reconnect.
I'm just excited to be here.
And you asked me
to start by introducing myself,
so I'm I'm a professor of psychiatry
and behavioral sciences
and also addiction medicine
at Stanford University
School of Medicine.
I'm also author of the book
Dopamine Nation
Finding Balance
in the Age of Indulgence.
And that's what we were talking about,
which I and Daniel's quoted in there.
I would have actually included
Daniel more in there
if I had if I were smart enough
to actually understand the
work that he does.
Thanks.
We'll get there with the ants
and the dopamine.
But really, just
what is dopamine nation about?
And what motivated you to write it?
So Dope Nation is kind
of a blend of neuroscience made simple
combined with practical advice
for how to live in a dopamine
overloaded world,
holding up people in recovery
from severe addictions
as modern day profits
for the rest of us.
Because all the neuroscience
in the world, as valuable as it is,
can't make up
for the experience of people
who have gotten into recovery
from addiction,
doesn't mean that
they should also posits a kind of global
hypothesis, tentatively posits
the hypothesis
that the growing rates
of anxiety, depression, suicide
and other mental health
disorders across the world
are caused, at least in part,
by the problem of over abundance
and the kind of lack of
appropriate friction in our lives.
In other words, the ways
in which our lives are maybe too easy
and the way that our primitive wiring
is mismatched
for this modern
ecosystem of overwhelming over abundance
OK.
One dopamine question,
and then I think we'll start
to see some areas of overlap
with active inference.
What could you say
to the role of dopamine
in reward and motivation
signaling like in wanting and liking?
And how does dopamine play a role
in behavioral selection?
OK, so dopamine is essential
for the experience
and motivation, reward and pleasure.
It may be even more important
for motivation than it is
for the experience of pleasure.
And I base this
on the work of my amazing
neuroscience colleagues
who have done experiments, for example,
where they engineer
a rat's brain to be
made with new receptors and discover
that if they give that rat food,
it will eat the food and seem
to take pleasure in the food.
But if they put the food
some distance away,
the rat will starve to death,
meaning that the absence of dopamine in
these key reward circuits
make it
such that that animal
is no longer
motivated to do the work that it takes
to get their reward.
And my neuroscience colleagues
like Rob Malanga
have said that for him,
the definition of addiction
is how
hard an animal is willing
to work to get their reward,
and that has direct application
to the clinical work that I do.
You know,
we all like what we like
and once we experience
the thing that we like,
of course we want to repeat it.
But the kind of fundamental
difference between
those who go on to develop addiction
and those who don't
is that those who develop addiction
are willing to work
very, very hard
to get their drug of choice
and are willing to give up
a lot of other things,
even when that pursuit causes an
enormous amount of personal cost.
Thank you for that.
That's really powerful
with professional thinkers
definition of how hard
they work to get it,
because it's like an action
oriented definition
that could be measured in
or proxy by different things,
especially clinically
as opposed to like in inference
or a purely cognitive
based report, like a survey.
How often do you think about
something like that?
And that's very interesting.
And that's I think
one of the themes that we'll pick up
on, which is action.
And for active inference,
it's right there in the title.
It's like
there's always going to be
a minimum of two.
And when we're talking
about behavior and cognition,
they're inseparable whole.
And then that plays out
in a lot of different ways,
like partially with the embodiment
and the inactive perspectives
that come to view.
But also just like,
as you
said, it's pragmatic too,
because it's relevant
to always be thinking
about action and cognition
as like a dyad in the context
rather than trying to separate them
and then find a correlation across.
Love it. Love it.
So I've been a psychiatrist for
going on 30, 25 years
and I would say the first half
of my training and life experience
and education
was really focused
on changing people's cognitions.
So focusing on people's
thoughts and emotions
and using language as a tool
to talk about those, to change those.
But as my career went on, I became more
and more skeptical
of this as a solitary pursuit
and more and more convinced that
what we need to do
is focus on changing behavior.
And when I'm dealing with patients
with addiction,
that is in fact now
my first intervention,
I will say
let us first change the behavior.
And in doing that experiment,
and then what I mean is abstain
from your drug of choice,
see what happens, and then let's make
certain inferences
based on what that experience was like.
For you.
And that's really atypical
in psychiatry today.
What we do
instead is we talk
and we talk
and we talk about
why the behaviors are happening
without really focusing
on changing the behaviors.
And I think we really that
that's not good
because, for example,
my patients will come in,
they'll be addicted,
and they'll say, I'm addicted
because I'm depressed.
Or because I have this trauma.
All of that may be true,
but we can't talk about the trauma
till the cows come home.
You have to change the behavior
and you have to do it
before you feel like it.
So that's really interesting, too.
Like patients will say, well,
you know,
I'm just not
I don't I'm not motivated to do
X, Y or Z.
So this is an early where I don't feel
I said, you know what, if you wait
till you feel like doing it,
you will never do it.
What you need to do
is change the behavior, experience
the impact on your feeling
by changing the behavior
and then take it from there.
So I totally agree with you.
It's this intense
narrative of the and emotion
and the actual actions.
And we almost always are focused
on, you know,
the cognitions and emotions.
And we don't get people to do enough of
just focusing on changing behavior.
OK, so I think that's our first theme,
which is this action orientation,
and that plays into the embodiment
and the inactive aspects.
But also
it has a kind of corollary,
this like, OK, first principle,
and that helps us perturb
the causal structure
by just looking at the end equals
one observational experiments.
Well,
your consumption will be correlated with
the price of oranges.
And then how do you actually get
at something deeper in the world?
And that's sort of a relevant
type of intervention.
So action
and also action first is pretty cool.
Any other thoughts on that?
Or we can go in a different direction?
Well, I would also say that this brings
to mind,
you know, you asked about surveys
and things like that.
Like I don't really like
just personally like I don't really
I mean,
I think there's value for, for,
for like survey studies.
But the problem is
what you really end up picking up
there is more about what
the dominant cultural narrative
is that explains
why people do X, Y or Z.
And you're not really tapping into
why they really do X, Y or Z
the other thing I would say that,
you know,
the way that we think about science
is that
it's not
a single person's life narrative
but I really believe that that
that there's science.
When you
see a series of individuals
over and over again,
you hear their stories
and you can recognize
very similar patterns.
And then you do an intervention
and you see the results,
and you do that repeatedly
with many people over time.
It's not like your classic,
you know, a clinical study,
but it feels really true and real to me
in a way
that a lot of times
clinical studies don't or can capture
some of the deeply nuanced
complex aspects of human behavior.
Know,
I love the way you think about things.
So crazy.
I know that now you're like, OK.
I didn't know what was going to
come next. So yeah.
All right.
So back to the book
and also to connect this to an active
inference theme.
So decision making in active inference,
like policy selection, the PI variable,
the way that different possibilities are
ranked is not just by their reward
or their expected like value or utility,
which would be common
in a kind of reinforcement
learning or a reward
maximization framework.
But there's like two components
that go into that policy selection.
There's a epistemic knowledge oriented
like learning and curiosity
intrinsic motivation,
and then there's a pragmatic.
So there is a utility element
and the ability to dial in on utility,
but also there's the ability
to kind of pull back.
And when you were describing
your book structure,
certainly while reading it
and as you described it,
there was like an epistemic component
neuroscience made accessible
for those who might not have
the molecular background,
but also like on page 48
with a baseball game, it's
just fun
for even those who might have seen it
in a different way.
And then there's the pragmatic part
which uses the stories
to kind of connect to useful tips.
So where do you think
epistemic and pragmatic value
come into play
in how you're thinking about this
so.
So epistemic is interesting,
and thank you for showing the examples
related to my book.
Because that helps me also understand
what you mean by those terms.
So what I find really interesting
about
how to intrinsically motivate
people with addiction
is that if they have a framework
in which understand their behavior,
it really does help
people change their behavior.
It's really a framework.
And what's fascinating to me
is that neuroscience talks
and everything else works.
And by that I mean
when I
explain people,
their behavior
with a neuroscience
framework, it carries a lot of currency
for people. It feels real.
You know,
it feels like it's almost like
let me just throw it out there
like a modern day religion.
Like you could
you could use
a very different framework,
like you could use a moral framework,
you could use a philosophical framework.
People don't resonate with that
the same way they resonate
in neuroscience,
which is why
I use the neuroscience framework.
So I think and
people carry it around with them.
So for example,
I use this extended metaphor
of a balance, pleasure,
pain, balance and gremlins
represent neuro adaptation,
and they hop on the pain side of balance
and for example,
I had a reader write me and say,
you know,
really tried
really hard to quit smoking.
So whenever I have an urge
to smoke a cigaret,
I just imagine those little gremlins
going right up to popping up and down
the road.
I'm not going you're not going to win.
You know, I'm going to outlast you.
So that's really interesting.
People will, you know, it's like a free
we need those epistemological frameworks
that we project on to the world
to help us cope, make decisions
last in difficult situations.
I thinks
maybe even one where that that person is
experiencing their experience
the way that they're thinking
about their behavior and inference.
It's like the the metaphor
that you're
bringing the baseball game for,
the neurotransmitter synapse,
the gremlins,
even some of the more flowcharts,
like how different stages
are related to each other.
There's always like a person's form
moving through it,
and then that provides
a lot of accessibility
to enter into that space
and like kind of
imagine counterfactual ways,
which is our
human cognitive expertize in a sense,
is not to memorize 11 digit numbers
even outside of ultra specific training.
It's to like, OK,
if the neurotransmitter
like when I looked at that example,
I thought, well, where are the glia?
Are they the crowd?
Are they like, what are they doing?
Are they supporting this pitch?
And then there's that time scale.
Then it already opens the door
to questions
that the molecular representations
like, Oh,
well then it's a done deal, right?
With the pre and post synaptic.
Huh? Yeah, right.
And I think you know,
obviously these metaphors
are like
a gross oversimplification and things,
you know,
can't explain all of the phenomena
but as you say,
if we try to explain it all
and we get too complicated,
then it feels to people
like memorizing a list of numbers.
So it has to be true
enough to represent the real science,
but not so complex
that people can't take it with them
and apply it in their
everyday, everyday lives.
And it also it takes it out of that,
the kind of uncanny valley and example
there would be like the ribosome.
It's a purple blob, right?
Well, it's really not,
but it's represented so commonly
and then that locks in.
But then at the baseball game,
we know it's not so different scale
roads, approachable.
And then anyone
who wants to look into the receptor
slash glove.
Yes. Yeah. So
what's.
OK?
That was kind of exploring
what was the second area,
which was like the epistemic
and the pragmatic, like always
pairing the knowledge,
gaining with the useful
and then recognizing that there's a time
for the more knowledge oriented.
Maybe there's a building on campus
that's more knowledge oriented.
And then also there's a time and a place
for what's useful.
And maybe
that's part of the conversation that
do you want to see or
how do you want to see it
with applied neuroscience?
Can you can you say what
you mean a little bit more?
I didn't quite get that.
Like connecting the epistemic
and the pragmatic,
the learning and research oriented work
with the practical tips
is, Oh,
you can act, how could it be,
how should it be?
How do we make that connect?
And like flexible and and work
yeah.
I mean, there's
obviously, you know, a huge disconnect
like this is this is the problem.
We're sort of in this ivory tower
where we're learning this stuff.
We're acquiring this knowledge
work where, you know, people,
you know,
neuroscientists like you actually
adding new knowledge.
But yeah, then
the question is
how do we get that to people
to actually benefit them,
you know, in their everyday lives
and also get it getting it to
to students
to give them a sense of meaning
and purpose in their work.
So it doesn't feel
so incredibly disembodied
from the world that we live in
and the reasons behind
for why we do
I mean,
why do we want to
acquire this knowledge?
I mean, you know, there's
there's there's not just
I mean,
maybe it is knowledge for its own sake,
but I think deeply people want to feel
they're contributing,
making the world a better place,
you know?
So I think
it's really important to to to
we need to do more to bring those
things together.
I feel
like, you know, medical education,
the so there's the pre clinical years
and then there's the clinical years.
And I know for me personally,
like those clinical years
where where I first sort of felt like,
oh, things goodness,
you know, here
I am interacting
with like real human beings
and trying to take this knowledge.
And also, I'm impatient.
I'm very impatient.
So I feel like the human interaction
I could see more quickly
that I was making a difference.
I didn't have the kind of patience
that it takes to be a scientist
in the sense
that you are
where you really have to have
deep, deep data.
So what you're doing matters
and that down the road
you will see it's
you know, it's it's application
unless you unless it's
just the beauty of it,
you know, for its own sake compels
you will in.
But I'm ultimately
a very kind of pragmatic person.
And so and I'm also impatient.
So I need to see that a lot
a lot sooner.
But how about you?
I'm sure you have any thoughts on this.
I'd love to able
Well.
Yes, very interesting.
And as
we were kind of joking about
before, like
everyone especially in an age
of specialization, abundance
of specialisms,
that being able to, like,
connect across them is really important.
Like having not had firsthand experience
in, for example,
any of the stories presented.
And that's like the microcosm
of the discussion with frameworks
and people's lives
kind of meeting from the ground up.
So patients,
that's an interesting thing.
And you point out
to like how different people
seemingly display behaviorally
different amounts of patients
and they probably experience
it differently too.
But also it's patients
for different things. Right?
Intermittent fasting of this many hours
of this many days,
all the things might align
for one person at one time
and it very easy to be patient
behaviorally versus
not versus some other strategy.
And so
trying to think about that in an active
inference way,
it's like
in active inference,
the question is always about
what is the decision right now
or inference and action.
So how should I be perceiving
and learning and acting in the moment?
Given the
long horizon or the stated horizon?
So what is going to be the best move
in this chess move?
Given the kind of uncertainty
about the future of the game includes
including like the uncertainty
about what
the other side will do
or something
like that,
or even uncertainty over
one's own actions
and then patience is like, Well,
what is happening when the best action
selection is to
not engage with something?
So what is it that actually values
for something that is valuable?
Like, it's easy to be patient
for something
that's just a purely negative
experience, right?
Or just a hold off, not interested,
but being patient, we kind of
are applying to something
where it's like, I do want to
call this person before the time
I said I would call them,
but I'm getting impatient or like,
I want this research project to be over.
I wish that this was faster,
which everyone involved in research
or maybe analogously like
it would be awesome if myself
or if this patients were
seemingly on
their recovery faster or something.
So how, how does it come to be that
sometimes we wait in the moment
and other, other times we don't
and like,
is it OK or when should we do stuff?
Yeah, oh
gosh. So much there.
So let's start with your question.
How how does it come to be?
How how do we I mean, you know,
I quote you in the book
saying that the world is
sensory rich and causal poor.
And I just love that quote
because it wraps up in this nice,
nice little package
that the problem
with highly reinforcing
drugs and behaviors,
which is that in the moment,
they feel like the right thing
and they feel good.
But the long term
consequences of repeated use
is to get us to a
potentially very dark place.
But we don't
necessarily see the connection
between those two things. Right.
So how is it
that we come to see that connection?
And I think as a psychiatrist, having
listened to thousands
and thousands of people's narrative
life stories over time,
that one of the ways that we get
there
is actually
the autobiographical self narrative
that that that words are tools
and that those tools are a way
not just to organize past experience,
but actually create roadmaps
for the future.
So it's not just, you know,
the way that we tell our stories
about our lives are very,
very impactful.
I think Lucho or somebody like that
said said that
then autobiographical narrative
is the only way
that we have to document live time,
which is really, really interesting.
Like for all of the cool technology
that we have
the only thing
that documents
live time is storytelling.
So and I've seen this again and again
when my patients come in
and they tell
an autobiographical narrative
in which
they are constantly
the victim of the world
and other people,
and that's why they're addicted.
Those people are not going
to get better.
And part of what I need to do over time
is to move them toward what I consider
to be a more truthful narrative,
which is that
there's always something
that we have contribute to the problem.
You know,
maybe we just showed up
and that was our contribution,
but it's never
always entirely somebody else's fault.
And for people who get into sustained
and robust recovery,
you can hear the difference
in their autobiographical narratives,
and one of the front
of the narrative differences are able
to tolerate the shame
that comes
with acknowledging
their character defects
and the mistakes that they made
and what they're contributing
to their messed up situation,
which is just basically
closer to the truth.
So telling
the truth is really important.
Telling truthful stories
is really important.
And I think
that those stories
actually become the tool
by which we are able to remain patient
in the face of,
you know, delayed gratification.
That's what keeps us able
to not to do something
that we should do in the moment.
We don't feel like doing or to abstain
from doing something
that we feel like doing in the moment
but shouldn't do.
And, you know,
whether that story takes or framework
based on neuroscience or whether there's
a religious
or spiritual framework, like,
you know,
my reward will come in another life.
There are many different ways
to build that story,
but that story has got to be
the thing
that allows that person
to kind of you know, delay
this gratification in the service of,
you know,
living a
more flourishing life.
I'd like to ask
a follow up question from the Adam
giving remark
where a pixel nice screen name asks,
How can we learn to build patience
for healthy habits?
OK, how can we learn to build?
That's so, so good.
So I think there are a couple
there are a couple stages
First
it's to recognize that
when you first stop doing a bad habit,
you will suffer more, that the initial
or your initial experience
will be increased pain, not
like immediate reward
from stopping that bad habit.
So I think so
that like setting up
expectations in that way,
but that the longer you can go
abstaining from that bad habit,
the faster you will get to that place
where you
begin to feel better
and you don't miss that bad habit.
In fact,
you start to reap the benefits
from that.
You have to know it's going to get worse
before it gets better.
Everybody talks about
practicing mindfulness
and what that is,
but actually there's
almost no better opportunity
for practicing mindfulness
than to give up something
that's bad for you,
that you really like a bad habit.
Because what will happen
is it'll stir up all kinds.
It's very disruptive.
And I think
and the ability to learn
that you are not your
thoughts and emotions,
but that you can stand
some distance from that
and not respond to that.
But just objectively observe
those things is is really important.
I think
giving up a bad habit,
bad habit with other people
so that you're not doing
it alone is really important
because you can then,
you know,
go to other people
and sort of suffer together
and then I think meaning making
is really important.
So to give up the bad habit
so that you yourself can feel better,
but also what is the what is the greater
meaning of abstaining from that thing?
And often it's
a consumptive process and,
you know,
a greater
meaning could be
saving the planet, right?
I'm doing this for me,
but it's also good for the world.
Thanks for the answer.
So, yeah,
one of those words
you mentioned was expectations,
which is a poor idea
in Bayesian statistics
and a long history
of like Bayesian brain
predictive coding,
predictive processing,
many different approaches
to neuroscience behavior and so on.
And active inference does
build on
that and uses the idea of expectations
as far as expected futures
and things like that a lot.
And so it's interesting
to think about the role of dopamine
and like you said, set up for this
because then it'll basically go that way
and you'll stay on track.
Whereas if you expect
to go faster or different,
you're going to feel like worse
or anxious or uncertain
about how to proceed.
And it's totally modeled
in an active inference way
by thinking about like
the estimate is not how many points,
how many are
am I getting, it's
how many points relative
to how many points I expect. Right.
And one can be doing better
or worse or as expected.
And if things are going
well, there's positive valence.
If things are going as expected,
it's like neutral valence,
and then you're going poor.
There's like anxiety
and negative valence, right?
So that is one way
where moving from like a reward
only perspective to be like,
well, yes,
there's an expectation of reward
and precision along that path.
Will be pleasurable or neutral,
but it's not going to be like
winning, winning, winning.
It'll be like
neutral with oscillation around
neutral right?
Yeah.
And I can tell you,
you know,
in the
like the lived experience
of treating patients,
this is absolutely key.
So one of the things that we do
in our clinic is to help people
get off of chronic opioids
like, you know,
OxyContin or Vicodin or Norco
or chronic benzodiazepines like Xanax,
Valium out of them. And,
you know,
you would think
this it's not that complicated,
but actually a lot of patients
are looking for help with this
and can't find it.
And they find it in our clinic.
And the one thing that I would say
we provide, which is the real value,
is to establish appropriate expectations
because what happens
is they'll both see a doctor
and they'll say,
I need to get off of Xanax
or I really want to get off the Xanax.
And the doctor said, oh, that's easy.
You know,
just go down by you know, you know, 50%
of your starting dose
over the next week and you'll be fine.
And the patients
do that
or same thing with therapy, opioid,
they do that
and they're in horrific psychological
and physical pain
because they're in withdrawal,
or maybe they even have a seizure,
right?
So their experience is totally worse
or much worse
than what their doctor predicted.
And first,
the doctor is like
the respected authority.
So then they feel angry.
They also feel betrayed.
They also feel like they're weird,
like why? Why am they come to us?
And my patients told me again
and again,
Doctor, aren't you
the most important thing
you said to me
when we went down by my opioid
or my benzo by a little bit
and we go very slowly,
is that I would feel worse
before I feel better.
And I really do
I way emphasize that
so that if they go
and they taper and it's not even
it's not as bad as what I
then they're like happy.
It's like you know,
what you told me
was going to be bad for a while
until my body would really refill.
But we equilibrated
and it was bad,
but it wasn't like I could do
it, you know,
so that setting expectations
is it's really, really important.
Like in the real world.
It's almost like there's a wanting
for reduction or sobriety,
but actually they don't like it
behaviorally, not on the psychological
what are they thinking?
What does the survey say?
But actually like, well,
you don't like the green room
if you aren't spending your time in it.
It's how we would say it
about the other kinds of animals.
So it's kind of like interesting,
like where do we like
something but not want it?
What is dopamine
and other neurotransmitters? Doing then?
How about
situations where we do or don't
have patients?
Like they are such great
questions
and entry points for our own life
and for research.
And that's like kind of the bridge is
the introduction of the paper
or the context for
the grant is like kind of
could be that bridge.
But then sometimes it
is more about how it appears
rather than how it is.
Yeah.
And I think
the variable of time is so important
for all of these things.
Like if I'm going to,
you know,
we can sign up for a lot of suffering
if we know it's time limited right?
Like, OK, I can do this
because Doctor
Lin said I would feel like crap
for two weeks
and I would start to feel better.
And so, you know, you can hang in there
for that or whatever or you know,
the intervention is that that
makes a difference.
So returning to the quote on
page 75
about the world is sensory
rich and causal for you know
personal communication when 2018
because I think there's
a very interesting difference
or something
and I'm thinking about it now.
Oh interesting.
OK, I'd love to hear that.
So I think that was
when I was just beginning
to learn
about active inference and free energy
principle and Bayesian brain.
And I was thinking
well wow it's not just like
signal detection
on the pixels or whatever
there's the causal inference
and then that's like you followed up
like we know that donut
tastes good in the moment,
but we are less aware
that eating a donut
every day for a month
adds £5 to our waistline.
We, we get that understanding
through personal experience,
relationships, science, research.
We build that understanding,
that expectation of cause in
and then all of a sudden
our behavior is like more natural
to switch in the moment.
So I was thinking, you know, starry eyed
graduate student,
sensory rich and causal for
I think now I might say
sensory poor and causal poor
because the sensory part
is of extremely limited
frequency, only some
chemicals that we can detect,
only some sounds that we hear
even within a domain
we're not always paying attention to.
Our blind spot
is evidence
that we're
in a generative model of vision
because the sensory data
is sparse and noisy and early.
So it's like in the world
that sensory poor and causal poor,
you can finally disengage from this,
like watching a movie
perspective.
And it's like it's so generative, it's
so much about our expectations as well.
It's the cause.
And also
we're not just watching a movie,
a vision,
and we're expecting a big thing
and generating even that most
yeah.
So powerful.
I think this is really why
I think there's
so much power in our self narratives
because I think those self narratives
that we project on to the world
absolutely impact what we perceive
I just yesterday
I was meeting with a very beloved
patient of mine
who happens to be, you know, a, a
graduate student
who has had
a really mixed experience in his lab
and feels like
he hasn't made any friends.
Nobody likes him
and also feels like
like they're all jerks
and they're kind of out to get him.
And what I tried to get him to see
is that he has a narrative
and a vision that he
superimposes on the world
such that all
he remembers
or appreciates
is like the slights, right?
And he doesn't
he doesn't have access
to the other things
because he's so entrenched
in this particular version of the world.
Just to give like a personal example,
I talked about in the book
my very complicated relationship
with my mom
and how part of the healing for
my relationship
was to get out of this place
where I'm always saying
how terrible she is,
and instead
appreciating really
the great things about her,
which are many
and also
what I've contributed to the problem.
But before I could do that,
I was engaging in behaviors
that just reinforced my worldview
and I'll give you
a very tangible example
you know,
one of
the things that that
had bothered me about her
was that I would email
and she wouldn't
respond to my email
in a timely or what
I felt was appropriate action.
And this came up at one point
where I, you know, did
something that was really important.
I felt it was really important.
And she didn't respond
and I gave her a week
and I gave her a month
and I gave her three months.
And I got angrier
and angrier as time went on and,
you know,
railed about it to my husband,
say, see,
this is exactly what I'm talking about.
And then I was eventually
just able to just forget about it
and whatever move on.
And then I was on email
and kind of looking through it
all kind of cleaning on my
and discovered
that my original email
that I had sent to her
that I was so angry
that she hadn't responded
to was actually in my draft box.
It had never been sent.
And I think there are so many ways
in which we do that
where where
we don't even get the opportunity
to see it like it was just
in this case,
I did
but we, we sort of
do these things to sort of,
you know,
hold on to this worldview,
which typically has other people
being the bad actors
and it doesn't force us
to look at ourselves.
Thanks.
So one
interesting piece there is like
we won't be totally on board for
the past
being a reconstruction in the present,
the generative aspect of memory.
And then it's also easy to believe
in the generative aspect of the future.
It hasn't happened yet.
We don't know about it.
And then
as per that predictive coding
type of like sensory generative model,
we're also now casting.
So it's like the past, the present,
the future, you know,
the three areas that we know about,
they're all generative.
So there is reception of signals
but also like
all of those are generative.
And then you pointed to like this idea
of kind of a cognitive degree of freedom
in our narrative.
And so we might even model
that as like
an action or a movements
in a narrative space.
And so
how do we make appropriate actions
in narrative space?
Because do we just say,
OK, graduate student, no,
they're awesome,
or how do we know
what to say and how.
To do it or not?
Yeah, so
so this is a student of mine
that I mentioned, this patient of mine
who just
happens to be a graduate student.
So he's about to,
you know, finish up
and go on to a post-doc
and I actually suggested that to him
as sort of as an experiment
because I often talk about this
as inspiration, you know,
as you move on to your next lab.
Why don't you try an experiment
where you just
take as like an a priori supposition
that everybody in the lab loved you
that that
that they want the best for you,
that they are your friends.
And any time you have like a paranoid
thought or a negative thought,
about them
really critically, appraise
that and you can doubt that and fact
check it or reality
test it with somebody else
that you know, and I think through that,
he might be able through
iterative processes
because it's such a feedforward cycle.
The problem is when we're paranoid
or suspicious of other people
they sense it and they way back off.
And then as soon as they back off,
we get more paranoid as we should
because they've given us the signal
that they back up
and that it's reinforcing cycle.
So if we kind of discard
that primary narrative
and then act in the world
as if right not and not in a fake way,
but as if certain things were true
that we didn't
necessarily believe upfront.
And I often ask my patients to do this
all the time,
especially with my patients
who are addicted
and whose lives are being destroyed
by their addiction.
I say to them,
you have to imagine
and essentially have faith
that giving up your drug of choice
will lead to a better life.
Right now,
what you see is two choices
you see continuing to use and
or stop using and being miserable.
And I'm holding out to you
the possibility of stop using
and being
happy or being happier than you are
while you're using
but it is a leap of faith
because you have to are going to have to
wait a long time
and do a lot of things
where really you don't feel that at all.
You just have to believe that
it's true and approach every day
as if that is true.
The other thing I talk about in my book,
which is maybe a little bit of a paradox
given what I just said,
is this idea of radical honesty
and how important truth telling
is to this process.
Again,
because truth telling is important
to build true narratives
and true narratives
are important
to be able to know how to make decisions
going forward in our lives.
And it's a small thing, but,
you know, my
my patients will say
and patients in recovery will say,
I can't lie about anything.
When I was using,
I, of course, lied about my drug use,
but I also lied about stuff
that it didn't even matter.
And my favorite anecdote is my patient
who's now in really sustained recovery,
doing great.
He says, you know, when I was using,
I was in the lying habit.
If I if I was in McDonald's
and a patient called and said,
hey, where are you?
I'd say, hey, I'm a Burger King.
If I was a Burger King, my patient,
my friend would call and say,
Yeah, I'm at McDonald's.
So it got to be like this
where like I like lies about everything.
So part of his recovery
and this is what I actually
prescribe to patients
is radical truth telling.
Like you cannot
tell a lie about anything
because that's telling the truth,
I think helps us
first of all, it's it's
cognitively effortful.
But secondly, it really grounds us in
what is true and real
and helps us in an iterative fashion.
Stay closer to that
to build these truthful narratives,
which I think are really important.
So so there's a bit of a paradox there
because I'm saying on the one
hand,
pretend stuff
that you don't feel is true,
but which might be true,
which you can't see,
but at the same time
be really honest about
like your daily actions
nice.
Here are some of the
active themes
that I kind of heard their
action as a self-fulfilling prophecy
and action as being in the business of
acquiring evidence
for a given generative model.
That's a big theme.
And also
in order to switch action policies,
there has to be
a transient suppression
of precision on the policy.
Like if we're sitting down,
we have to transiently implicitly
or explicitly believe
that it could be a different way.
Otherwise we'll just continue
to get evidence that we're sitting down
and then
it's a very active way
to kind of escape that Gaslight paradox.
So you we're talking
about setting a competent prior
for the next epoch
and so that just today you're low
on how you believe others
think of you and uncertain
or your low and precise but
it's actually all in the past
now behaviorally
and then in your next endeavor
you could just try
starting higher in an unknown future
if you just peg it
higher and try to be more precise,
which is going to look like
being more skeptical
looking for evidence on the upside.
And so it's like
instead of focusing
on the
past and trying to re narrative
ize the past,
we can include the behavior of the past,
which for sure is in alterable
into a prospective narrative
of the future
that makes actions
like patients maybe more plausible yeah.
Love it.
I mean, of this, like love that science
speak, it's so exciting
and it maps so well to like,
you know, these kinds of aphorisms
or sort of the approach that we take
in psychiatry and psychotherapy
by using very different language.
And that's always really exciting.
And it just reminds me so much of,
you know,
the Alcoholics Anonymous saying
I'm taking it one day at a time,
which is so fundamental
for this whole process,
because what happens when we take it
one day at a time,
it means that we wake up
and we say the past is the past.
The future is the future.
All I need to do today is focus
on what I can do today to make my life
and your life and our lives
a little bit better
without putting too heavy on me.
Like I'm an
I'm not going to go
and like
save people in Ukraine, obviously,
but what are the things that I can do?
I can pick up that piece of garbage.
So it kind of narrows the time scope.
It forces us to be in the here and now,
which also expands our senses
so that we can take in more actual data
so that I'm not like ruminating
and cogitating on my own,
you know, sort of self-involved,
you know, problems,
which is where like,
you know, most of us
spend a lot of our headspace.
How do we do that? But we do.
But instead,
I notice that there's like
peanut butter cup wrapper on the ground.
I could pick that up, right?
That's one thing
that I could notice
that I have the urge to lie about
why I'm late for this meeting,
but I could not
I could choose not to do that.
I can choose that today.
That's kind of exciting to me.
That sort of opens up
all kinds of possibilities
because I'm
not a future catastrophizing.
I'm also not future grandiose thing,
you know,
we're like, Oh, I have to do this.
I have to do that,
or I'm not going to be good enough.
I'm not ruminating on my past.
I'm saying, You know what?
Today is the only unit of time
that I really need to focus on.
And string, I would say, is my patients.
A string of good days
makes a string of good weeks
and a string of good weeks
is a string of good months.
And before you know it,
you've got a couple of good decades,
and that's a lifetime.
And that's a life well lived,
which is what we all want.
And to
even bring in one other active
term, the Affordance,
which is the capacity for action
which comes from
the ecological psychology field,
the affordances, relational.
And so it's about like the motivation
by that entity
and the agency that they feel
they do or don't have
from a narrative perspective
and the affordances
that the niche
scaffolds and provides for them or not.
And also the narratives
that the niche provides or not.
And then the that
is what is going to be engaged
in that
behavioral decision in the moment.
And then you also talk
about like adding friction
as like a pragmatic strategy
that I'm sure everyone has experimented
with variously on different facets.
But it's like it's an example
about the pragmatic tips,
but also they're connected to behavioral
and cognitive
modeling in this
perhaps even formal way.
Yeah, exactly.
Well,
we covered many fun topics,
like just a few
that I kind of wrote down
where patients,
I guess the patients
who you clinically see
and having patients in the moment
and then expectations action
and taking action
as a first perturbation,
then the dopamine
as a reward
and epistemic and pragmatic value.
And there's a lot of interesting
research on active inference
and dopamine signaling
and then a lot of active terms
like action
priors, confidence, precision,
narrative information,
like all the amazing terms
and just very fun and also powerful book
and a lot of great material.
Thank you, Daniel.
This has been
really fun
as I knew
it would be as talking to you as always,
illuminating and
surprising in fine and positive way.
I always learn that I have
so much
respect for your,
you know, intelligence and creativity.
It's always exciting
thank you.
And hope to talk to you
and the others
from the farm in the future.
Sounds great.
I see you.